cargo planes like this md-11 will soon
be transporting the most anticipated
vaccine of the 21st century
prior to the coronavirus lufthansa cargo
invested 5 million dollars to upgrade
its facility at chicago o'hare
international airport to handle a lot
more pharmaceutical cargo
200 tons a day to be exact so when
pharma companies began to develop the
coronavirus vaccine
lufthansa was in a fortuitous position
vaccine manufacturers reached out to the
company which has just 19 planes in its
cargo fleet to help distribute millions
of vaccines in record time
it's a product everyone on earth needs
as quickly as possible
but distributing the various vaccines to
the entire world
is going to be a massive undertaking it
will require solving huge logistical
challenges
the different vaccines need to be kept
at various cold temperatures
transported to isolated and hard to
reach areas and fit on different sized
planes
nobody knows exactly what's going to
happen with the vaccine there was an
estimation that we probably need
approximately 8 000
freighter flights to globally distribute
this vaccine we don't have that many
aircraft
prior to the pandemic 50 of all cargo
shipments were transported on passenger
aircraft
in the same luggage hold as our
suitcases but that
all changed in march boom now you have
no passenger aircraft so now everything
is going on the freighters
that's david he and his team took us
behind the scenes at lufthansa's cargo
facility to see how it's preparing to
move vaccines through this nearly 110
000 square foot terminal that runs
around the clock it's all done by a crew
of over 200 highly qualified personnel
who can load two fader planes full of
112 tons of cargo every day
through the facility we could probably
transport anywhere from 2 to 10 million
vaccines every day we do expect that
once the vaccine is ready that a lot of
it will come through this facility
not many cargo facilities have the
massive cooling infrastructure required
to handle large shipments of covered
vaccines
if you have a vaccine or something which
got
you know too high of a temperature or
too cold of a temperature it might not
be
good for the patient anymore bano works
for db shanker
a logistics company that specializes in
transporting pharmaceuticals with strict
temperature controls
and is partnering with lufthansa to ship
the vaccines
in the pharma industry as you can see
all over the place it says two to eight
degrees that's the typical way you ship
pharma
so the the biggest challenge is to keep
that product at this defined temperature
from the moment we pick it up to the
moment we deliver it
but lufthansa cargo is equipped to take
on the challenge
before covet happened we made a huge
investment here and it's really it's
old-school stuff
giant freezers and fridges that are
connected and monitored
we have all these airlines asking us can
we use your warehouse because
we happen to have the infrastructure
ready for
covet lufthansa's 5 million investment
resulted in two new rooms
the first one called pph is for items to
be stored at 15 to 25 degrees celsius
we are here in the pph room varma room
which stands for perishable passive high
temperature 15 to 25
this is the place where we store the
shipments
coming in from all over the world until
delivered
the pph room can store all sorts of
things like flowers
stem cells and live fish its 15 to 25
temperature range
is designed so nothing gets too hot or
too cold
but that's not the only specialized room
lufthansa has
welcome to our freezer room which is
setting 80
minus 18 celsius degrees it's suitable
for the frozen goods
usually we have a smaller packages like
this one
small to medium boxes like those can be
packed with your regular old ice packs
or dry
eyes to keep the products inside fresh
or cool but with dry ice there are
restrictions on how much of it you can
load onto a plane
you're very limited on a passenger plane
because the dry eyes will
take the oxygen out of the air so if if
we have
too much dry ice here and we are
standing all around here
after a certain time we will not be able
to breathe for pharmaceuticals that
require even cooler temperatures
pharma and cargo companies use
nitroglycerin which could be especially
vital for
pfizer's vaccine since will need to be
stored at minus 70 degrees celsius
or minus 94 degrees fahrenheit nobody
can setting minus 94
so those are canisters filled up with
nitroglycerin
and the aroma vaccine is put inside
the vaccines you've heard about all have
different temperature needs
while pfizers needs to be stored at the
subarctic temperatures
moderna's vaccine needs to be frozen at
negative 20 degrees celsius if it spends
more than 30 days in refrigerated
storage
astrazenecas can be stored at the same
temperature as a home fridge for up to
six months
the big challenge will be the minus
70-80
celsius airlines and freight forwarders
have to invest
in mobile coolers because you will not
build a cooler like this for minus 70
degrees because if you think about you
need ppe material to go into it
i couldn't go like this into a minus 70
degrees
the good thing is pfizer has already
created its own container that uses dry
ice to keep its vaccine cool for at
least 10 days
other vaccines that don't require such
low temperatures like moderna's can use
already existing solutions like these
envirotainers
the battery charge on here is 100
the set temperature on this is minus 20.
these envirotainers especially designed
for transporting pharmaceuticals
can keep everything inside at
temperatures as low as minus 20 degrees
celsius
they even have their own power supply
enabling them to operate without being
plugged in for 10 to 15 hours
which allows them to withstand long
flights there's cords here
that plug right into the outlets that
are in the containers there
when we have these containers here they
still need to be
maintained as far as their temperature
is concerned because they run on a
charge
they won't stay long in the facility but
they have a home to sit into until it's
time for them to go
but in the event of flight cancellations
delays or shipments to remote locations
battery-operated containers can pose a
risk you cannot have nothing
except airplane engine running inside
they don't want your phone
on so can you imagine how it would be if
you have
10-15 containers plugged in that's
impossible
the lufthansa facility does have one
more way of keeping things cold
this is where all the uods or the
pallets that come off the aircraft
they get stored in here this is my
favorite part of the warehouse i call it
bumblebee
as you can see it is a little bit like a
vending machine
basically a giant storage system using
this 30 year old giant vending machine
like device lufthansa is able to store
pallets in three levels of stacked rooms
with garage door-like openings
18 of the rooms are temperature
controlled and each can store two full
pallets of pharmaceuticals
and the only the only thing that's been
in this warehouse longer than this
machine
is this machine right here still running
running strong no problem
when it's time to retrieve a shipment an
operator will have bumblebee go right to
the appropriate door
retrieve the pallet and load it onto a
transporter that will take it directly
to the plane
some of the pharmacarco may find its way
onto pallets like this
specially trained operations managers
put these together based on weight and
volume distribution all while trying to
maximize the space available on the
plane
the more we maximize the more extra we
can take on the flight there
it's really just it's a game so good
builders
are tetris players they have very good
spatial vision
if a pallet like this is going on the
md-11 the plane we saw in our visit
it can't just be cube-shaped the contour
is built to the shape of the aircraft so
this is a
main deck position you want to maximize
space so that's why you see that
curvature here
cargo that's loaded in there cannot go
outside those boundaries
because otherwise it'll damage the
aircraft and there's a distance of two
inches
that it's got to be away from that wall
in order to
keep it in a safety control distance yep
every pallet has to be built around
where it will be on the plane
and what shape the interior takes at
that position while the front offers
more height
the tail does not
all right let's take you up to the md11
we're going up to the cockpit right now
please watch your steps walk carefully
as the space is tight between the
pallets
so as you can see up here on the
aircraft it's pretty much a skeleton
you know all it's very thin walls
that you have out here it's just like a
cardboard
and that's all that's protecting the
aircraft so you don't want weight
because as soon as you put more weight
on an aircraft you lose cargo
pharma is gonna be transported on our
uods these locks are what holds the
pallet from
moving back and forward and
also upward positions the only
difference between cargo and pharma is
you have your
temperature restrictions you just notify
the crew and tell them put the whole
main deck
at that temperature or the lower it
holds which will be the forward hold
in front of the aircraft downstairs if
you can set that temperature as well
ops agents like ricky have to get
everything right within the confines of
the plane
weight limitations and weather
conditions these
are white uh plastic as you can see it's
different from this other one
this is just clear plastic this is
regular cargo
and these are our temperature controlled
uod's and we put this white plastic here
as a protective covering so it can
reflect the sun or anything that'll keep
you to
the temperature that is needed while
it's outside when it's
heavy rain snow sleet all that stuff
accumulates on the cargo
when you move that into the aircraft
that drips into the avionics compartment
it can happen on an aircraft that the
avionics compartment just goes blank the
entire aircraft is dark that is a huge
risk
so when that happens our ops team they
have to basically make sure there's no
water anywhere that aircraft sits there
until the next day until everything's
dry until everything's inspected
and it can fly and all this has to
happen within a very limited time frame
we have a ground time of uh two hours
and a half to offload the aircraft and
load it that's as much time that they
give us
that's for a full turnaround if cargo is
not loaded perfectly
then shipments could be delayed someone
could get hurt or pharmaceuticals on the
aircraft could be deemed unusable
if the aircraft is delayed until seven
in the morning you gotta stay until
seven in the morning
we as operations were the final check
that we have
to prevent anything from happening while
lufthansa has nine triple sevens that
can carry 103
000 kilograms its other cargo aircraft
the md-11 seen here
can carry only 90 of that or about 93
000 kilograms
and it was never meant to carry cargo in
the first place the nd11 was originally
built as a passenger aircraft
we converted ours to freighters we have
three md-11s left in our fleet we were
supposed to no longer have them
they're old aircraft they're very nice
very beautiful but very old aircraft
they're also very difficult to manage
from
an operational point of view they should
have been phased out already at the end
of
by the end of the year but they're
keeping them a little longer because of
the demand that we have
the main difference from this the triple
seven and this this aircraft has three
engines
and it's got one in the back and that's
uh one of our critical points
this aircraft is so tail heavy uh that
we have to have to have
extra precaution on not tipping it
because if you have too much weight in
the back
this aircraft will go up and those
wheels will come down
the md-11 is like playing tetris if the
four of us standing here
on an empty aircraft walk to the back of
the aircraft that air airplane tilts
and you can no longer fly that aircraft
that's that's an aog aircraft on ground
while the crew has to worry about the
md-11 popping a wheelie the process is
much easier with lufthansa's triple
sevens
the triple seven only has two engines
and they're
located in the middle so it's very hard
for it to tip
so safety safety related the triple
seven is a lot better
fuel efficient than the md-11 a triple
seven aircraft which is the largest
aircraft we have that
that is a freighter aircraft commercial
freighter aircraft holds approximately
100 tons
so in this facility we could run two
full fader aircraft every day
coming in with pharmaceuticals and
delivering them and while the lufthansa
facility is ready to handle 224 tons on
two triple sevens a day
that still might not be enough planes
there was an estimation that we probably
need approximately 8 000 freighter
flights
that's 8 000 freighters carrying only
the vaccine
but remember these flights also normally
get loaded with shipments like furniture
pets cars and all sorts of other cargo
and this is all happening as we enter a
holiday season in a year that has
already put
massive strain on the air cargo industry
it is going to be a huge congestion
my understanding is there is going to be
a huge competition for space so
if amazon pays more than the united
states government
for the space on the aircraft then we're
you know they're selling it to amazon
but passengers are flying less because
of cover 19.
so why not just load up all those
passenger planes with vaccines
you can't really convert an aircraft
like that i can't go boom
you know now it's a freighter aircraft
the biggest problem with that is the
door
so you can't you look around here you
can't fit that through a passenger door
the increase in cargo shipments has
presented its own challenges for
lufthansa
suddenly everybody needs qualified
people who can work on freighters
everybody here at the airport is trying
to poach our people our biggest
challenge
in in the middle of this pandemic is
suddenly all the other competitors want
our people
and we have limited resources to train
new staff so you really
you're you're steve's that has been here
for 42 years and your husmeras and all
these people that are qualified
and know what they're doing they're all
being approached by everybody else
because everybody needs them for
for for kovit and for freight at the
same time
lufthansa cargo had to implement social
distancing mandatory masks and
temperature checks in his facility
we're an essential business obviously i
always say you know try moving freight
on a zoom call it doesn't really work
right so
we have to make sure that our people
stay healthy distance travel times and
the urgency of the vaccine will add even
more complexity to this already
complicated process
you need a lot of space but only for a
few days
and then you don't need it anymore
especially when you go to africa when
you go to remote areas
it might take more than 10 hours to be
there and while that's a large scale
problem to solve
there are some micro issues that need to
be addressed closer to home
we're getting electrical forklifts to
handle the pharmaceuticals if you're in
the room
with the pharmaceuticals you don't want
to be using a propane forklift
for too long because it can be a
contaminant these are all the
adjustments that we have to make
in order to make everything work and a
lot of things we're learning as we're
going
we will definitely do everything
possible
to accommodate because this is huge
if you do pharma or vaccine
you know that there is a patient behind
so that automatically gives you a sense
of
you know even more responsibility to
make sure that
not to say that the other freight is not
important but
you know this is this is something which
we obviously have to be
uh monitoring any minute because it
if it goes bad it can it can cost
the life of a human being
[Music]
it gives you big sense of responsibility
and they don't evolve